TRUMP VERSUS THE SMART SET.
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
MEDIA DRUM BEAT CONTINUED
TODAY AND IN TO THE TONIGHT
ABOUT THE SALACIOUS TIDBITS
IS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOT SMART, HE DOESN'T READ,
IS HE NOT CURIOUS.
IS HE A VILLAGE IDIOT TYPE.
ACCORDING TO WOLF'S BOOK AND
MANY OF THIS HAS BEEN PUSH
BACK ON BY THE WAY FORMER
HOUSE WAS INCOMPETENTLY RUN.
TREASURY SECRETARY STEVE
MNUCHIN AND FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF REINCE PRIEBUS BELIEVE
TRUMP TO BE AN IDIOT.
GARY COHN THE PRESIDENT'S
TOP ECONOMIC ADVISOR REGARDS
TRUMP AS, QUOTE, DUMB AND
THE PRESIDENT'S TOP NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR H.R.
MCMASTER CONSIDERS HIM,
ACCORDING TO THIS BOOK TO BE
QUOTE A DOPE.
WELL, OF COURSE ALL OF THIS
TRUMPERS.
>> SOME OF THE MORE
SALACIOUS ENTRIES, THE FACT
THE ASSESSMENT IS ALL
CONSISTENT OF THE CLOSEST TO
THE PRESIDENT WORKING WITH
HIM AS BEING ESSENTIALLY A
HE HAS GOT NO ATTENTION
SPAN.
HE READS NOTHING.
>> IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN IT
SEEMS.
THIS IS AN IDIOT SURROUNDED
BY CLOWNS.
>> THE BEHAVIOR, THE
DISPOSITION OF THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE HORRIBLE CHOICE YOU
HAVE TO MAKE IS DO I STAY
HERE AND WORK WITH THIS
CHILD WHO BEHAVES LIKE AN
ARROGANT FOOL, BEHAVES LIKE
A BABY.
>> Laura: POT, KETTLE,
BLACK, JOE.
WELL, OF COURSE, THEY ARE
ALL ENJOYING THIS MOMENT
WHERE TEAM TRUMP SEEMS TO BE
PILING ON THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE THEY ALL THINK IT
VALIDATES THEIR OWN VIEWS
PRESIDENCY AND BY THE WAY HE
EATS A LOT OF BAD FOOD.
OKAY, I'M GOING TO HAND IT
TO THEM.
I THINK THEY ARE RIGHT ABOUT
THIS, TRUMP ISN'T TO
ARTISANAL CHEESES AND
DOESN'T MUNCH DOWN ON KALE
AND FANCY WATER.
GOOFY.
DO THESE PERPETUAL GROUSES
SAYER THAT'S NOT A STRATEGY
FOR EXPANDING YOUR OWN
MOVEMENT.
I STILL REMEMBER WHAT THE
SAID ABOUT MY OLD BOSS
UNINTELLIGENT.
NO ONE EVER WILL BE.
REAGAN WAS A MAN FOR HIS OWN
TIME.
HE WAS THE FORMER TWO TERM
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WHO
WROTE AND THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT CONSERVATISM.
BUT, LIKE REAGAN, TRUMP IS
EXTREMELY SHARP AND HE HAS
THE PULSE OF THE PEOPLE.
AND I KNOW BECAUSE I HAVE
SEEN IT.
HE HAS UNCANNY ABILITY TO
CONNECT WITH THEIR HOPES AND
AMERICANS THAT WHAT MAKES US
SPECIAL IS OUR PEOPLE.
AND AS FOR THE SO-CALLED
SMART EDUCATED PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOW CRITICIZING TRUMP, I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS.
AMERICAN COMPANIES AND
AMERICAN SECURITY?
AND WAS IT SMART TO LEAVE
OUR BORDERS OPEN LIKE SWISS
CHEESE ALLOWING ILLEGALS TO
STREAM INTO THE UNITED
STATES, TAKING AMERICAN
JOBS, SAD LING TAXPAYERS
WITH THE COST OF EDUCATING
THEM, HOUSING THEM,
PROVIDING THEM WITH
HEALTHCARE?
WAS IT SMART TO GET INTO
DRAINING OUR COUNTRY OF
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, TOOK
THE LIVES OF SO MANY OF OUR
FINEST MEN AND WOMEN?
WAS IT SMART TO EXPLODE OUR
FOREIGN POPULATION NOT
THROUGH A SMART MERIT BASED
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM BUT
WAS IT SMART TO BORROW
TRILLIONS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES ONLY TO SEND
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS TO
COUNTRIES WHO HATE US?
IS IT SMART TO CREATE A
GOVERNMENT MANDATED
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT DROVE
SO MANY DOCTORS OUT OF THEIR
PRACTICES, JACKED UP
PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS AND LED TO CANCELLED
I DON'T THINK SO.
THIS WAY ON MY RADIO SHOW
TODAY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS HIS OWN
WRITER, HIS OWN PHRASE
MAKER, HIS OWN PRESS
SECRETARY IN MANY SENSES.
YES, DONALD TRUMP IS AN
YES, HE IS NOT LIKE EVERY
OTHER PRESIDENT THAT YOU CAN
THINK OF WHO WAS PACKAGED,
WHO WAS FABRICATED, WHO WAS
BEING HANDED, YOU KNOW,
THINGS THAT WOULD MAKE YOU
POPULAR AGAINST ENORMOUS
ODDS BY TAKING ON THE
TWO-PARTY DUOPOLY THE ELITES
OF BOTH PARTIES WHO HAVE,
LET'S FACE IT, RUN THE
COUNTRY INTO THE GROUND.
IS HE A GENIUS.
>> Laura: MAYBE HE DOESN'T
PULL OVER THE LATEST
HE HAD GREAT SCHOOL.
HE NEVER PRETENDED TO BE A
GREAT ACADEMIC.
NOT MANY PEOPLE ARE.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE EXPOSED AND NAMED THE
PRETENDERS, THOSE ELITES IN
POLITICS, MEDIA AND BUSINESS
WHO HELPED DRIVE AMERICA IN
TO A DITCH NO MATTER HOW
BADLY THEIR POLICIES AND
IDEAS FAILED THE PEOPLE.
THOSE FRAUDSTERS ARE ALMOST
NEVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
TIRED OF SEEING AMERICA
LOSE, TRUMP REVEALED THEIR
AGENDAS, HE NAMED THEM, AND
HE MADE US SEE THEM TO BE
THE FRAUD THAT THEY ARE.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY HAVE
BEEN VENGEFUL EVER SINCE
FURIOUS?
WHAT'S THE POINT OF BEING
SMART IF YOU NEVER LEARN.
TRUMP SOMEBODY SOMEONE
NEEDED TO STEP UP TO BE THE
VOICE OF FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN.
HE BEAT ALL THOSE
CAMPAIGNERS WITH THEIR FOCUS
GROUP TALKING POINTS AND
SLICK AD CAMPAIGNS.
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL OUT
THERE LISTENING TO THE
PEOPLE WHO COUNT, YOU.
>> I WAS IN NEW YORK AT A
BIG EVENT RECENTLY, AND I
TAKE A LOT OF PICTURES WITH
POLICE AND WITH FIREMEN AND
WITH THE MILITARY AND ONE OF
THE POLICEMEN CAME UP, AN
OFFICER AND HE SAID SIR, I
WANT TO THANK YOU, MY 401(K)
IS THROUGH THE ROOF.
MY WIFE IS SO HAPPY.
MY FAMILY IS SO HAPPY.
>> Laura: DUMB?
I DON'T THINK SO.
HE IS TELLING THE STORIES
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR.
PERSONALIZING, STERILE
STATISTICS, CHARTS AND
GRAPHS.
REAL ANTIDOTES AND THOUGH,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE GOT TO SAY
WRITING A MILLION-DOLLAR
CHECK INTO JEB BUSH'S SUPER
PAC.
I WAS SURE HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD WIN AND I WOULD BE
WORKING IN HER
ADMINISTRATION THERE IS A
BRILLIANCE IN TRUMP'S
POLITICAL STRATEGY.
PERHAPS ITS GREATEST
INSTINCT WAS A SIMPLE
BUILD THE WALL THAT PROMISE
WAS SACROSANCT AND HELPED
HIM GET ELECTED.
THE BEST THING TRUMP CAN DO
IS STICK TO HIS CORE
CAMPAIGN PROMISES,
ESPECIALLY THAT ONE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO FALL, I
DON'T THINK, FOR WHAT THE
FAILED ELITES MIGHT BE
TRYING TO SELL HIM.
THEY MAY HAVE MORE POLITICAL
INSTINCTS THAN MOST OF THEM
AND MOST AMERICANS WILL SEE
THAT HIS THINKING IS EXACTLY
THE TYPE OF UNCONVENTIONAL